[Musica]
[Applauso]
nell 87 avevo 9 anni una nuova famiglia
e sperimentavo per la prima volta la
vita in campeggio eravamo in toscana e
anche all'epoca si organizzavano
attività rivolte esclusivamente ai
bambini e io e mio fratello eravamo
risultati vincitori di un improbabile
carnevale estivo
io vestita da vaiana con il foulard di
mia zia e mio fratello da samurai con la
camicia di mio cugino l'animatore per
per premiarci ci ha invitato e si è
rivolto a me con l'amorevolezza a cui si
rivolge
normalmente cui ci si rivolge nuovamente
ai bambini e mi ha chiesto di dove sei
di roma gli ho risposto io molto
candidamente suicidando la sua ilarità e
di tutti quelli presenti all'interno del
campeggio che partecipavano a questa
iniziativa
allora lui addolcendo il tono di voce
come se da quello che vendesse la mia
risposta ci riprova e mi dice sì certo
ma da dove viene
eravamo in toscana ricordare per cui io
sempre più candidamente da roma
lui sorride e ci riprova una terza volta
ma non capisce e neanche io capisco
ecco ho voluto iniziare da un aneddoto
per parlarvi di una delle sfide più
importanti che ci consegna la
globalizzazione la convivenza negli
ultimi anni io mi sono occupata di
accogliere orientare e informare un gran
numero di ragazzi provenienti
prevalentemente dal corno d'africa e
anche di sensibilizzare i miei attuali
concittadini e ai temi delle migrazioni
milanesi di origine di adozione come me
e di passaggio
ecco quella esperienza anche
quell'esperienza mi ha aiutato a
comprendere che le immagini che vengono
utilizzate per raccontare oggi e anche
ieri i fenomeni migratori non ci aiutano
a proiettarci nel futuro
per questo voglio fare un esperimento
insieme a voi
proviamo a chiudere gli occhi quando
pensate all'immigrazione oggi quali
quali immagini vi vengono in mente
ci sono immagini più ricorrenti di altre
vedete delle persone riuscite a
distinguere i volti di quelle persone a
comprendere che ciascuna di loro ha
delle attitudini personali riusciti a
comprendere le loro storie individuali a
comprendere che possono avere bisogni
differenti aprite gli occhi erano barche
tende muri fili spinati massa indistinta
di persone ecco quelle immagini
schiacciano il nostro sguardo su
l'eterno presente uguale a se stesso da
decenni ed è per questo che non
utilizzerò immagini oggi ma solamente
parole per raccontarvi la mia idea le
parole qualcuno diceva che erano
importanti e utilizzerò le parole per
provare a costruire insieme a voi un
nuovo immaginario
sono convinta che chiunque di voi abbia
avuto la possibilità di viaggiare e
visitare altre città sa come riconoscere
un luogo accogliente e non solo per il
grado di simpatia dei cittadini ma anche
e soprattutto grazie all'accessibilità
dei servizi e delle informazioni
disponibili in città
accessibilità che passa anche attraverso
l'utilizzo di una di una lingua di uso
comune
ecco comprendere le informazioni e poter
così accedere ai servizi rappresenta il
primo passo per un progressivo processo
di integrazione e inclusione sociale per
iniziare a sentirsi parte soprattutto
nelle città perché nelle città che gran
parte degli immigrati quando ha la
possibilità di scegliere risiede
preferisce risiedere perché nelle città
che possono trovare lo spazio fisico e
sociale per accedere più facilmente alle
reti di sostegno sia dei connazionali
che degli autoctoni e avere così
maggiori opportunità dalla formazione al
lavoro ed è per questo che bisogna
partire dalle città gli spazi
innanzitutto gli spazi pubblici perché
gli spazi pubblici perché sono preziosi
sono diffusi sono disponibili sono
accessibili sono gratuiti
spesso sono anche belle e accoglienti
pensate ai parchi urbani o ad alcune
piazze e rappresentano la possibilità di
incontro per molti soprattutto le
persone che vivono in periferia
generalmente più poveri spesso immigrati
è ancora più spesso richiedenti asilo
ecco immaginate una strada una strada in
cui il passaggio è molto frequente
potrebbe essere dotata di segnaletica
una comunissima segnaletica stradale
oppure di display digitali dei più
evoluti display digitali in cui è
possibile accedere a tutte le
informazioni di cui si ha bisogno per
muoversi in città
in più lingue soprattutto gli spazi
pubblici i parchi urbani e le piazze
potrebbero essere tutti dotati di rete
wifi in modo che tutti possano avere
sempre la possibilità di accedere alle
informazioni e tutti non solo gli
immigrati
immaginate un quartiere in quartiere che
ha caratterizzato la presenza dalla
presenza di una pluralità di culture
potrebbe dotarsi di operatori
transculturali che facilitano la
comunicazione tra i residenti tutti i
residenti quelli di oggi quelli ieri
quelli di domani
e immaginate che le istituzioni
pubbliche attivino campagne di ascolto
periodiche in cui attraverso cui il mont
o monitorano attraverso cui monitora la
qualità delle relazioni tra le persone
attraverso appositi questionari che
aiutino anche al dialogo al confronto
immaginate che i luoghi di aggregazione
comunemente utilizzati dagli immigrati
possono diventare spazi sociali aperti
dedicati all'incontro e alla conoscenza
reciproca
oppure pensate che alcuni spazi alcuni
edifici abbandonati possano diventare la
sede di associazioni di immigrati o di
associazioni che si occupano di
immigrazione e che esistono nelle nostre
città in questo modo possono essere
riconoscibile e possano garantire a
tutti un livello di maggiore serenità
perché io sono convinta che quando
vedete una ventina di persone la
domenica entrare in una chiesa
voi siete sereni
e siate sereni del fatto che quelle
persone vanno a pregare
se voi vedete cinque volte al giorno 20
30 persone entrare in uno scantinato e
non sapete quello che fanno non siete
sicure se sapete che esiste un luogo in
cui quelle persone possono andare a
pregare
voi siete più sicure e anche le persone
che vanno a pregare possono essere più
sicuri e serena
ecco questo perché perché esistono
determinate caratteristiche del vivere
insieme la condivisione l'aggregazione
la possibilità di riconoscersi la
possibilità di convivere
sono tutti i termini che declinano il
concetto di cittadinanza e anche se è lo
stato che determina le regole per
l'accesso alla cittadinanza le città e
le istituzioni locali possono avere un
ruolo determinante per attivare processi
di partecipazione attiva di tutti i
cittadini inclusi anche agli immigrati
vi faccio un esempio di partecipazione
attiva
un altro piccolo aneddoto esiste un
quartiere a milano che ha suscitato da
sempre la mia curiosità porta venezia
che oltre ad essere uno dei luoghi
raccontati anche nei promessi sposi è
conosciuto come il quartiere africano di
milano
ebbene nel 2013 il confine a sud del
mediterraneo si era spostato nelle
strade di quel quartiere
all'inizio quando sono arrivati i primi
gruppi di migranti dal sud italia
il quartiere è diventato un pezzo del
quartiere è diventato una centrale
operativa di primo soccorso in cui era
disponibile tutto dai vestiti al cibo
ali ai medicinali ed era tutto gestito
da immigrati eritrei etiopici che erano
arrivati prima 20 30 40 anni e che dal e
che da quegli anni li risiedevano o
avevano attività economiche nel momento
in cui le persone sono diventate 300 400
quest'equilibrio a un po vacillato e
soprattutto le difficoltà che che
generavano un numero così grande di
persone nelle strade perché li fate
venire qui questo è un quartiere
residenziale non è un campo profughi
voi ci guadagnate qualche cosa
ecco io non lo so chi ci guadagna meno o
di più però so una cosa che la domanda
che interessa pormi è un'altra ed è la
domanda che vorrei porre anche a voi
come possiamo guadagnarci tutti senza
perdere la capacità di distinguere e
senza perdere la capacità di dare valore
alla solidarietà
ecco secondo me l'esempio di porta
venezia racconta di una risorsa di una
risorsa in termini relazionali che
spesso è contenuta esclusivamente nelle
dinamiche delle comunità straniere
ecco quelle risorse la qualità di quelle
risorse potrebbe diventare patrimonio
comune essere integrata in un sistema di
accoglienza che coinvolga tutta la città
in modo che questo coinvolgimento questa
partecipazione è riconosciuta possa
possa attivare processi di reinvenzione
delle
felicità perché le identità sono in
continuo mutamento e poi un'altra cosa
un'altra piccola cosa giusto per per
portare una riflessione su un'altra
risorsa
voi sapete quanto vale in termini di
ricchezza e lavoro degli stranieri oggi
in italia
127 miliardi
secondo l'ultimo rapporto della
fondazione moressa e le rimesse
secondo bankitalia le rimesse negli
ultimi dieci anni hanno più che
raddoppiato il valore della finanziaria
del 2016
64 miliardi ecco immaginate che quel
sentimento che spinge le persone alla
condivisione l'appartenenza possa essere
il motore per cui si istituiscano anche
strumenti finanziari non so proviamo a
chiamarlo fondo sociale di investimento
urbano dedicato all'inclusione sociale a
compartecipazione vista cittadini e
istituzioni pubbliche e private
cittadini italiani i cittadini immigrati
finale ecco quello strumento insieme ad
altri strumenti insieme o da soli
imprecisi contesti diversi
vi dicevo la segnaletica
la tecnologia per la comunicazione gli
operatori transculturali spazi dedicati
campagna di ascolto fondi per
l'investimento sociale nelle città ecco
quegli strumenti
possono rappresentare le risorse per
costruire la convivenza è forse così
possiamo guadagnarci tutti
[Applauso]